I just absolutely love this story I'm
starting with today Colorado election
officials are formally ordering a
recount in Lauren bobert's Congressional
race which she won by 550 votes against
Challenger Adam Frisch now if you look
at the reporting they say very clearly
this is not expected to change the
result
um but this is so fascinating because
these people on the right who just
insist everything stole and recount
everything audit everything blah blah
blah blah blah now there's actually a
legitimate reason for a recount to be
ordered in a race that Lauren bobert is
of course extraordinarily relieved to
have survived because she almost went
down after just one term in Congress to
Adam Frisch so there's an article from
the Colorado sun and it says Colorado
elections officials formally order
recount in race between Lauren bobert
and Adam Frisch bobert leads fresh who
has already conceded by 550 votes the
recount is not expected to change the
outcome of the Third the congressional
district race
this is a mandatory recount and it was
expected this was a closely watched race
bobert leads fresh the margin is 550 but
the law is that you must have a
mandatory recount when the number of
votes separating the two leading
candidates is less than half of a
percentage point of the number of votes
cast the margin is
0.3 percent meaning that the recount
must take place
the Secretary of State Jenna Griswold
who's a Democrat added the results of
the District 3 race reinforce the fact
that every vote matters Colorado voters
have made their voices heard I'm
ordering the recount in accordance with
Colorado law this can begin immediately
recounts rarely shift the margin margin
Beyond a few votes which is why Frisch
conceded in the closer than expected
contest the Third District leans heavily
in Republicans favor this is this is
just great so I don't think it will
change the outcome
um I believe Lauren bobert really won
this is still a fascinating race because
as the article points out that Third
District in Colorado is quite a
right-leaning district and the fact that
it came down to 0.3 between an incumbent
Republican member of Congress Lauren
bobert and the Challenger Adam Frisch
means that Maga really isn't safe and we
saw Madison cawthorne defeated and
removed from the House of
Representatives we'll talk about him in
the next segment and his crazy outgoing
speech but there is a real question as
to the viability of Maga going into 2024
and just making Lauren bobert have to
wait a little bit longer is a really
great thing that I can certainly get
behind now when it comes to 2024 we
still don't know what is going to be the
level of strength of these Maga
candidates I think it will be different
if Donald Trump remains in the race and
becomes the nominee versus if Trump
remains in the race but loses the
nomination versus if Donald Trump simply
bails on the primaries because it's
looking so terribly we don't know which
of those three scenarios ultimately will
happen but if it's the ones that are not
so good for Trump this may be it for
these Maga people it we we will be years
removed from Maga
in November of 2024
and it would be great if people like
bobert were removed and ended up being
just sort of a blip in American
political history uh cawthorne was
removed
Marjorie Taylor green won easily Lauren
bobert won but by a very small margin
let's hope it keeps going in that
direction and listen Maybe the recount
will find that actually Adam Frisch won
but not expected to and I don't believe
that that will be the case I've had such
trouble finding a great razor where I am
not cutting myself or getting those
Nicks on my skin which are so common
with the cheap disposable razors you
have to meet our sponsor Henson shaving
Henson actually manufactures parts for
the International Space Station and the
Mars rover and they are bringing that
exact same Precision Engineering to the
Shaving experience it hurts when you
shave because blades extend too far and
thus they wobble slightly but with their
Aerospace grade CNC machines Henson is
able to make metal razors that extend
just
0.0013 inches that it's less than this
thickness of a human hair which means a
secure stable Blade with the vibration
free shave it also has built-in channels
to evacuate the hair and the cream no
more clogs no more rubbing your thumb on
the razor to get the hair out I use
Henson at home shaving is a great
experience now Henson wants to be the
best razor not the best razor business
which means you only need to buy it once
and it's awesome go to hensonshaving.com
Pacman add a razor and a hundred pack of
blades to your cart then enter the code
Pacman to get the hundred blades for
free that is a three year Supply the
link is down below